Speaker 1: So this next story, I know it's
going to be hard for a lot of people to see
beyond the physical appearance of the
individuals that we're talking about.
There are twin anti-vaccine brothers, the Bogden
twins who were actually of mimetic fame. They were
like crypto meme figures in in cryptocurrency
related memes. Both of these brothers,
whose physical appearance is bizarre and we'll
talk about that in a moment. They both died of
COVID unvaccinated within days of each other. Now,
if you're not familiar with these individuals,
these are Grichuk and Igor Bogden. If they were
known for a couple of different things, to some,
they were known for their their placement. They
figured prominently in cryptocurrency related
memes to others. They were known as having what
appears to be bizarre plastic surgery. If you look
at pictures of these individuals decades ago, they
look completely different. They, as far as I know,
denied having plastic surgery. As you can see,
you know, they have these cheekbones that are so
bulbous that, according to an Australian
newspaper they quote, threaten their own vision.
Extremely controversial and strange looking
individuals, they obtained doctorates by writing
what are considered allegedly meaningless physics
papers. They claim to be descendants of nobility,
et cetera, et cetera. They're both dead
of COVID. They're both that of COVID,
the Daily Beast writes. Their voyage through
the stars ended in a Parisian hospital
where both Rebecca and Igor Bogdanov had been
admitted on the same day after contracting COVID.
Groucho, the younger twin, died in ICU on
December 28th. Igor followed him on Monday.
Both were 72 years old. A source close to
the brothers told the French media outlet
Le Monde that neither had been vaccinated
against the virus. It is, you know, you can
read about these individuals if it's interesting
to you, but it is another one of these stories.
Both unvaccinated, both dead of COVID. And I
don't, you know, but particularly in this case,
because of their appearance and the entire
sort of called the personality around them.
A lot of people are just laughing at this. I
really don't find it funny. So it's just sad. It's
sad. And the vaccine doesn't protect anyone, 100
percent. Colin Powell very immunocompromised, but
had the full regimen of vaccines died from COVID
or COVID complications. It it doesn't protect
everyone. But don't you want a better shot? Don't
you want a better shot? If the suit of armor is
available and you're going to walk through
a forest where arrows are going to be fired,
you might never confront an arrow. They might go
whizzing next to you. They might never actually
hit you. But wouldn't you rather the suit of armor
if there are going to be arrows flying? That's my
view. And many of you know that already. But the
bogden off twins, the crypto meme twins, both dead
of COVID within days of each other and in the in
the next segment, I'm going to tell you about my
confrontation with COVID. A lot of people, I
tease this like ten days ago and people have
been writing saying, David, what's the deal with
that? I wanted to wait to have what was hopefully
the full story. I believe I have it now, and I'm
going to be talking about that after the break.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman. You can also follow the show
on Facebook facebook.com slash David Pakman
show. We'll take a break. We will be right back.